creating notebooks for data exploration
for creating educational content
or even writing full-on research papers
is always fun
but to make sure that the content is
reproducible across all systems
is kind of tricky with nvidia videos
we're trying to solve
some of these issues the main motivation
behind mpg produce is to make sure
that domain experts who are not
necessarily devops or programming
experts
are able to create usable content from
their research projects
even with tools like condi and pep
available locally
to make sure that the local environment
is
set up correctly across different
systems is hard the current use case of
uh mbt produce is to make sure that we
have a one click or one command
reproduction of a research paper or a
replication of a research paper
in a containerized environment the
figures that we get
today from running a script or a
notebook should be the same
figures that we get 10 years on the line
and with nb reviews
we try to achieve that the main features
of mb reviews
is that it lets you reproduce a notebook
inside a container
which is created using a docker image it
also lets you
start up a jupyter lab instance inside a
docker container
which again builds upon our docker image
and it also lets you
reproduce entire projects using a bash
file or
some sort of a make file uh it doesn't
just needs to be a notebook it could be
it could be
a c file it could be some julia code it
could be latex files
could be the paper itself that needs to
be compiled
and nvidia use is available on wi-fi
and you can install it using pip install
npd produce
it does require docker to be installed
locally so if you're on
windows or mac there is stopper desktop
available for you
and if you are on linux you have docker
engine available for you
and let's have a quick demo of nbd
produce
so nd reproduce can fetch
uh urls it can fetch uh it can run local
uh notebooks so in this case we fetch a
url from github
which is just a hello world example of a
notebook
and when we do when we run this command
it will download the jupyter notebook
from the
from the url it will try to execute the
notebook
inside inside a container using this
environment and if you
if you look at this thing it says
jupiter sci-fi notebook latest
it's one of the standard uh docker
images from the jupiter topper stacks
and nvidia produce knows to look for
this image because nba reproduce
uh inserts uh and inserts a docker image
tab
inside every notebook in the metadata if
you look at the raw format of this
hello world dot
[Music]
which is ipv here if you if you look at
the metadata you could see this
tag docker image and it points towards
this
uh docker image which is hosted on
docker hub
and we can see that it has executed the
notebook and
by default nvidia videos will create a
copy of the image and it will
uh append reproduce at the end of
the end of the name of the notebook and
we can also open up the notebook to see
how it looks like
reproduced one when we click on it it
will
[Music]
yep this is how it looks like so we have
the images are the images are reproduced
and we can see them here
the other feature of nvgpus is that you
can start up
uh you can start up a jupiter lab or
jupiter
notebook instance by default if we do
npd produce live it will start with
jupiter lab instance
and just just like how you start a
jupiter lab on
in the command line
[Music]
let's wait for url
so nvidia videos live will start a
jupiter lab instance inside the docker
container
so you have the environment available
from the docker
container rather than your laptop or
your desktop
watch url here right here let's click on
this
and this will open up a jupyter lab
instance
and let's go into work by default it
means the directory as work
and this can be changed but
as we click on the notebook we can see
we have
a reproduced notebook available we also
have this folder pandemic which will
have
a local letter and we have hello world
which was our original fetched
notebook let's close this thing
and the third feature that i would like
to show
is it just doesn't work with notebook it
also work
with full-blown research products for
example this is
this is the this is the port behind a
research paper
let's look at the the reproduce file
then
use that script and
you can see that in in this part of the
core in this part
of the batch file we need to create all
the figures and the
results using the type of using a python
script
then we compile the paper itself and
then we also compile the content
the slides of the paper to reproduce
this folder we just put in the reproduce
and it will
start the process as the code takes
a lot of time let's close this for the
time being and let's go back
to our slides
so there are some similar ideas as
compared to mvd produce
there's a tool by google called caliban
which
works some sort of in some sort of
similar way where you can have notebooks
inside the other containers running
locally
and you can just pass those numbers to
google platform if you want like for
example more compute power
then there are some geospatial specific
docker environments
uh which build on top of darker
darker stacks and then then there are
probably many more ideas like this
and for future work the project is
currently under active development and
we would love to get more ideas for
improvements and contributions from the
community
feel free to open up any github issues
for discussions or send a pull request
or even
contact me if you have any ideas how we
can improve this project
the link is available here for the
project itself and the second one is for
the documentation of this project
thank you